[Applause]
hello and welcome to research in focus
I'm Gretchen Hugh's Inga today we're
gonna talk about data analytics in the
cloud and I'm talking with distinguished
scientist Sergey Chowdhury and
researcher by Lu ding both in the DMX
group of Microsoft research data
management and exploration thanks for
coming today both of you so let's start
with a level set give us an overview of
the field of data analytics and then in
general what are the new research
opportunities in data analytics ok this
has been a very active field of work
both in the industry as well as in
research a simple way to say what data
analytics does for you
is we collect data and data analytics is
sort of the technology that allows you
to get to the insights in the data and
that insights in turn you know leads to
a lot of business innovations so when
you step back and say what have we
achieved so far today we can deal with a
huge volume of data tera and petabytes
of data and in many cases exabytes of
data so we can process a lot of data
well and we can handle scale but this
scale although we can handle it is not
cheap handling at last scale cost us
money so that's one challenge how to
reduce the cost of data analytics as we
go along the second problem is what we
can process it a well getting the data
into the data analytic systems is a lot
of work and that process hasn't yet
smooth as much as we would like that
process to be because the smoother you
make that process the more is the reach
of the data analytics because it can get
in more data and handle those the second
aspect of that is configuring this
machinery of data analytics it's not
simple and if you don't set it right it
would often not perform as well as you
want and this is sort of the second
challenge and the third challenge that I
think we feel is very important and
goes back to the point of our cost is
how can we sort of get back up the
envelope answers because this is really
makes it easy for us to deal with large
volume of data relatively low cost so
what specifically are you doing to get
to that in the research community right
now so one idea is approximate Quarry
processing and what that does is it says
when you ask me a question just as we do
in real life if you stop me and say how
much do you think it is how long it will
take you to cook this dish or you know
how long it will take you to go from
point A to point B I might give you an
approximate answer I say well I think it
would be I'll be there between 20 and 30
minutes with all the traffic and
everything including yes of course today
we have maps and everything that makes
it easier if I ask you how much it will
take you to cook this dish I'll say yeah
25 minutes half an hour what it is this
we haven't used as much to this large
collection of the data if we did then
and we can answer these questions
relatively snappily in effect I am using
lot less resources to answer those
questions but it is important that these
answers are not way off because I'm
using these answers to decide where we
sort of focus to investigate right right
right well I'll ask you about that in
just a second
researchers are always trying to shorten
the amount of time between when data is
born and when we get insights from it so
what's the felt need there in our
current data analytics landscape what
problems are we trying to solve with
that shortening of the time I think that
the shortening that time is important
because if you look at the pace of the
world today like I'll give you an
example as supermarket decides to have a
sale event right or a departmental store
is going to have a sales event so they
want to launch the sales event but they
want to get feedback based on how the
first few hours went to understand what
you need to change either about pricing
or the morality so they want to react
quickly to the incoming data of course
in a robust way so if they can't get
that data in sufficiently early the
sales event or the promotion event would
be over before they can do
course correction or interview I think
that's sort of an example case we're
getting the data in quickly and being
able to analyze in a timely manner is
important and that goes back to your
point of shortening the gap in time
between analysis and ingestion of data
right so bilou talk to us a little bit
about the idea of Auto tuning and cloud
databases how do cloud-based databases
differ from regular databases and
ultimately how do we get rid of manual
tuning or do we need to do that okay so
the databases have been moved into a
very powerful but also complicated piece
of software so the it provides a lot of
tools for naps for the user to customize
the database so it works best for their
own web applications the usually is
precisely the user needs to figure out
what there are the best configurations
for their application and to get the
most out of the database so previously
there has been work on how to choose the
english's for databases but this again
provides another toolkit for the user it
requests the input from the user and the
user needs to use their judgment to
decide like when to use this tool and
how to use this - so this is just like
like nowadays you it's easier to drive a
car with automatic transmission yeah
then manual transmission but you still
need to pay attention to surroundings to
decide when to accelerate and when to
slow down so the vision of this project
is to automate the interim process of
database tuning so that when the user
just nature specify the metric and the
target they want to have and we will
figure out how to get there and we
actually go ahead and really get there
for you so in terms of the cloud actual
Azure provides a unique opportunity for
us to know within a database and 'nor
across multiple databases so but ranking
legal telemetry from the crowd we can
transfer and generalize this non
learning to millions of database in yeah
sure that's awesome
let's go back to approximate answers for
a second Sergey
why would in a database query because I
understand the idea of you asking me a
question
well I guess 20 minutes but if I'm going
on my computer and I do a query I'm
thinking I'm gonna get something exact
and that's what's been aimed for hasn't
it
why would close enough be better than
for sure yeah so you have to think about
cost if you don't think about cost or
latency or how much time it takes for me
to answer the question approximation
would not seem interesting right and and
so the challenge here is the following
if a and as you know we have been
accumulating data at a very rapid pace
so we have a lot of data for a computer
to go and look at that data one of the
two things have to happen it has to be a
super powerful computer means often like
a large cluster of machines who are all
working super hard to get that data out
and that cost money if you think about
the how much work the computer is doing
the time money you are spending in the
world of cloud disappearance relating to
money it would be a lot of money to
answer your question exactly
alternatively it will also take a lot of
time to answer it and unless you use
this bring all these resources to bear
very much large clusters what that means
is that I trying to get the answer I
have to wait for quite a while you know
so either from the latency or from the
cost or sometimes from both getting an
exact answers in a world of big data
when a lot of data has been accumulated
is expensive and what we are trying to
do is to give you a mode of answer but
you get a back-of-the-envelope feel for
the estimate before you know let me
before you go and spend that money to
get the exact answer so we are not at
all saying exact answer is not important
or that world will go away absolutely
but we are trying to have a portfolio in
that not always I have to see exact
answer and spend a lot of money instead
what I do is work in a world where I
sometime ask for an estimate and based
on their student I may say huh now let
me ask the exact question because I
really want to know this in an accurate
way right so is there going to be some
kind of customer retraining in
expectations or expectation management
in an approximate world versus
for sure world you know the realities
approximation happens already today if
you think about what happens today when
I face a large data collection and ask
I'm going to analyze that data often out
of the need to get an answer quickly or
to spend less money we say you know just
take last three months data don't bother
looking at older data just look at the
last three months data right or just
look at last week's data or just look at
the data from Pacific Northwest for now
don't look at the other region so the
customer base is already tuned to the
notion of approximation that said this
approximations are kind of ad-hoc
approximations well out of necessity
they are making some you know ad-hoc
calls to see which part of the data
they'll look at what we are trying to do
is to say let's bring to bear the
foundations of sampling sketches and
other powerful tools that we have
innovated we in the broader scientific
community and statistical community have
innovated over sometimes decades or in
recent years and bring it to bear to
answer approximately in a principled way
that's the journey we are in yes there
is some adjustment to be had made but I
think the idea of approximation is not
new yeah people kind of have that
expectation okay so database systems are
made up of a lot of moving parts and
pieces how can machine learning and AI
techniques make individual components
smarter and maybe our systems more
robust yeah I can start so what I'm
thinking about is that especially for
the cloud services now we have the
opportunity to collect a lot of
performance metrics which is not like
confidential data it's not illegal data
it's just elementary of the execution
characteristics of the databases once
you see one database we see - you see
millions of them you are starting to
discover some patterns from them so if
you are new customer come to the cloud
we can leverage this knowledge and
transfer our knurling to your databases
so that you can enjoy this intelligent
database picture from the start
right yeah so just to refresh another
way what pilou has just told you is
traditionally we have built up one piece
of software we sort of goes and gets
installed in many places this database
system goes on your data it works and it
works on my data in a very similar way
it has a fixed set of capabilities it
doesn't go and very much tune itself
based on your characteristics it
essentially gives an answer in a certain
fixed way no matter which data you point
it to the availability of the data that
Bilu talked about this availability of
the telemetry data from the cloud opens
the door for an investigation which says
oh I'm on Gretchen's you know world and
in that world I'm looking that that data
has a certain characteristics and now I
know how I can optimize the functioning
of this database system to suit her
environment better and if I were in by
loose work environment I may see a very
different patterns maybe she is very
bursty on how she you know ask questions
and I may do very different strategy and
how optimize the resource of the system
I think where we stand today that
opportunity is very much there and it
behooves us to explore that opportunity
are we ready today to call it a victory
that this data would has modified the
way the systems are going are going to
be built in the near term I don't think
we are there yet and the question you
raised about robustness is real Jeremie
systems take pride in being a very
dependable piece of software in the
enterprise so before we make these
transitions in a database to be based on
the telemetry data we have to be super
sure that we have the guardrails to make
sure they act in a robust way so that
they're certainly based on the data they
don't do something erratic and this part
will require just like software
engineering needs to be understood much
better and how we deal with these ml
powered systems or specifically ml
powered database system yeah so the
machine learning bit is is personalizing
yeah the search thing but it needs more
research to sort of exact solidify
whether this is going to be
something that's gonna play well in in
my world
yes exactly without creating unexpected
surprises and also just in a few words
there are two aspects of machine
learning
why is true how do we generalize this
knowledge to others the other ones how
do you adapt this knowledge to you so
actually we are doing both dimensions
Wow
that's exciting so let's talk about
self-service data wrangling it's an
entrance
I've throw back to the gas stations when
self-service was the thing first of all
what is self-service data wrangling and
how do machine learning and program
synthesis inform the research that
you're doing in this area yeah so when
you sort of opened our discussion you
asked what are the problems in data
analytics and one of the problem I
mentioned is the journey from having the
data to getting it to a point where I'm
ready to run powerful analytics on it is
a long one and one reason is of course
getting the data from a different system
where data is being born to the system
in which I'm going to analyze it you
know is some time not so easy to get to
moving the data from one point to
another the second reason is when the
data is born - when I'm analyzing it
often the shape of the data needs to be
changed like the data gets generated in
a certain way but I want to sort of
reshape the data before I analyze it
this task of reshaping and you can think
in terms of if you are familiar or work
with expressions often we sort of move
around and try to do it shape it in the
right way before we sort of run some
aggregate statistics or other stuff this
process is what is known as data
wrangling data preparation data cleaning
and this phase is often is extremely
labor intensive for human intensive the
push of self-service you know data
wrangling is to say how can I make it
easier not compromise on how you want to
shape the data but instead of a heavy
duty manual intervention where I have to
be a rocket scientist to learn it which
automatically means fewer people are
going to be able to do that which means
lesser amount of the data are going to
be analyzed can I put the power in the
hand of an user like you Gretchen and
the idea is
give some examples if I have the details
in a certain shape
show me the examples of what shape you
want to be for a couple of your data
items and if you show that to me what
self surface data wrangling try to do is
to say I got your example I know that
kind of problem second I know the space
of programs I can possibly do to reshape
the data based on your examples I can
narrow what program needs to be written
instead of you writing the program you
simply show the examples and the program
synthesis technology with the ability of
machine learning to rank various
candidate programs among the using your
examples which will fit best your
example can present you the program on
how the data will be automatically
reshaped and this is a very powerful
tool yeah so is this like autofill or
flash fill but only with programs
exactly right that's the right way to
think about it what flash field does is
that just for the you know just to
remind all of us is essentially you give
some example in an Excel saying that hey
I want this column to be like this and
you're really giving the example of this
reshaping for a couple of rows maybe and
then flash fill automatically helps you
fill in the rest right and so it has
behind it a space of programs it can
think about and it generates from it
well we are taking this idea using
exactly the same paradigm which is
example driven for you to indicate the V
shaping you want but we hypothesize many
people have written many powerful
transforms and they're available because
in enterprises out of necessity people
have written what we want to do is to
create a search engine for such
transformations the idea would we'll
give these examples and these examples
allow me to search over all the
transforms that we have seen including
the kind of transforms flash feelings
today already capable of and pick the
program that I'm know of that already
meets your requirements and this allows
that Gretchen when you write a
transformation Bilu can automatically
discover and leverage that and this I
think is very powerful little experiment
yeah and you know I
just think of how much autofill and
flash fill have done for me speed and
productivity wise I don't have to think
through all of the filling in each cell
and so on that I can imagine this would
be really amazing for this program
exactly I think this is really you know
for an area of this data wrangling you
know which has been kind of a
slow-moving feel and very manual this
combination of program synthesis and
machine learning together have really an
opportunity a kind of an unique
opportunity to reshape the field in
terms of new innovations that will come
and we are not alone in this and I think
there is a broader opportunity for the
research community to do even more here
you know that's great and that kind of
leads into my last question for you I'll
start with you by Lou sure what would be
the goal or vision of this research if
in a perfect world you were wildly
successful
what would the data analytics and the
query and the database world look like I
say for me this is how long my research
or interested in my current project it's
like right now the cloud services are
valuable in the sense that it offload
some of the overhead of management of
data and databases of the shoulder of
the users so that an average user does
not need to necessarily be an expert in
the field can go ahead and deploy their
own database services and use the
services without any friction to my view
of the future of the soil work is to
make the cloud services even more smart
so that the users don't need to worry
about the underlying infrastructure and
do a side job as a DBA right instead
they can just focus on their application
and business logic and rely on us to
figure out how to support them for their
applications so you need less expertise
on the huge outsource but it's more well
it's like a diamond crossing the
database services to average users yeah
or lower than average what would you say
would be well I think the world kind of
where we started right I mean I think
that from the time the data is born to
where we are getting the insights
the data I want this process to have
very little friction and be inexpensive
and if you think about it today it
requires a lot of manual intervention
and as data grows the cost goes up and I
want to shorten that I want data is born
I can get to the insights relatively
quickly and it doesn't cost that much
and everything we talked about today
lead to that direction and that's sort
of my uber dream
the uber dream I love that Sergey bailu
thank you so much for joining us today
I'm glad you came in I look forward to
seeing where this is going to go in the
future
thank you so much for the conversation
yeah and thanks for joining us for this
session we'll see you next time
[Applause]